[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
taking y'all to a spot that's very near
and dear to me this is a spot that my
friend Nancy showed me a few years ago
if you guys remember I did this Hawaii
vlogs from when I first started vlogging
actually quit vlogging ethic because I
thought it was [ __ ] annoying and if
you guys remember I fell on my [ __ ]
face at a very specific spot called
Allen Davis now when I came here back in
the day apparently was like a local spot
that not many people knew so even if I
said in there you wouldn't be able to
find it but I guess like you know you
know how white people do it they like
the blog and [ __ ] I guess more the
merrier
most people go up that hill which is a
scenic route but we're gonna show you a
different way to get down
[Music]
sexy bloggers tip number one if you see
a path with dead grass make sure that
you stroke your fingers through because
you try and look sexy as [ __ ] oh my god
but this is what it looks like behind
the scenes [ __ ]
[Music]
we just arrived at Allen Davis I'm
sitting here in the shade because the
wind is going a little bit crazy right
now so I'm trying to get these audios
like a speaker but check it out over
there right over yonder is the jump-off
spot now the sad thing about this is I
haven't been here in about three years
but the platform that I jumped off and I
did a belly flop has smashed my face in
the water it's actually gone so we're
actually gonna just do a small little
jump right off the rocks but just as a
heads up if you're not a dope swimmer
even around the first of October or the
first week of October the waves are a
little bit bigger so I do not suggest
that you do this if you're not confident
in your swimming it's gonna be a dope
spot the water is relatively clear and
if you do have snorkel gear I suggest
you bring here because there are
fissures in the water when y'all try and
come and get down here be careful there
are a few little rocks but a lot of
these rocks are thirty so you don't have
to worry too much about it but when I
came here about three years ago
literally there was a platform for us to
jump up and I [ __ ] smash my face
right there you guys remember that but
be a little bit careful I do suggest
when you come down you do wear
flip-flops or sometimes water shoes
because when you come back up and your
feet aren't really like calloused you
are gonna have to step on these lava
rocks to get back up there and it hurts
if you're a little [ __ ] ass [ __ ] like
me
[Music]
[Music]
now this is the part of Allen Davis then
everybody likes to chill out it's very
calm as you can see I came dressed for
Halloween as a reflector but if you guys
are scared to do the cliff dive cliff
Drive
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you guys are scared to
do the cliff dive you can always come
out here lay out on the beach and you
can wade in these little soft little
[ __ ] pools which I personally like and
then if you get a little bit more bold
and the water is high enough you can
move past some of these rocks at some of
the coral and then go right into where
that beautiful water is but be careful
cuz you might get [ __ ] up like me when
I jumped off I actually it was a little
bit shallow I didn't jump far enough
because I didn't want to bare some of
the locals because I don't want to show
them my skills too much but you know how
people get actually cut my [ __ ] foot
so I was bleeding a little bit
right off to the side but just as a
heads up when you guys go into that
water straight up you are gonna have to
come back out the same way and you might
cut your feet like I did but casualty of
war and I got to say rome wasn't built
in one day and neither was his
[ __ ] body getting a pose
[Music]
did you guys know that I want to be
Instagram hope from now on but the
problem with being an Instagram home is
that it looks a lot easier than it
actually is you gotta wait for a wave to
come like this and then real gracefully
come on wave coming at me one foot there
it is slim t-50 hashtag I woke up like
this
[Music]
I have a few of my favorite pastimes and
if you guys have been watching these
videos damn this wind swimming and
eating that's what it's all about we are
here at Waikiki which is the place that
I don't normally frequent however I
heard in Waikiki a lot of the food here
is coming up there's a lot of local
chefs that are showing their talent in
the kitchen so I'm over here at fired
world we're gonna talk to the Executive
Chef he's gonna have a sample some of
his dishes and he's gonna show us what
he's doing over here that other chefs
aren't doing out here on the island so
here we have the chef of this fine
establishment now one of the things I
like to do when I before I eat the food
is actually get to know what goes behind
making this dish I know a lot of people
I don't like Yelp culture is huge and a
lot of people like to place their
opinions on food before they even get to
talk to the chef or know what it's about
which to me is the probably one of the
most annoying things you know so if you
are gonna talk about food you should at
least know what goes behind it so chef
please introduce yourself to everybody
out there hi Richard Miller chef
executive chef fire grill one of our
signature dishes is a salmon and zoodles
which we have here preparation on this
is not as extensive as a lot of people
think what we do is we take a standard
zucchini and we shred it to create
noodles like you would in a regular
pasta dish or spaghetti noodle we had a
pistachio cheese mix we add Granny
Smiths apples
and Sweetie drop peppers to the final
product from there we take our salmon
now granted you can use
the salmon you want we also know on the
top we have a romesco sauce okay imma
just go ahead and bite into that Smith
get a little bit of that salmon and this
is a Keaney you said yes
[Music]
that's amazing as a flavor bomb that's
exactly what it is it feels like you're
eating a guilty dish but it's not no
it's you know I'm gonna take this
charred lemon too by the way and maybe
like squeeze it on top a little acidity
to it wouldn't be bad and that salmon is
cooked perfectly by the way too and I
absolutely hate it when I go to a
restaurant and they nuke salmon or they
do fish dishes overcook salmon actually
ruin the flavor profile 100% I'll tell
you straight up making sure you're ready
for this I'm ready I'm ready for this I
don't even know what I'm looking at
right now holy hell
Wow
this is
it's like a campfire it's a campfire of
flavor that presentation it's it's all
about it's all about that right there I
mean we did ours a little differently
due to the constraints of our kitchen I
don't have a hotbox or a god or a prime
rib underneath and sliced to order so I
had to think outside the box so what we
did is we we grilled it so that you know
guests can still have the prime rib you
know if they want it rare I can give to
you rare they want a medium rare and and
you know so on so well done we can do
that now we got grill marks on it great
well I'm uh I'm gonna have to get into
this real quick I'm gonna get to the
asparagus in a little bit because the
piece of meat is waiting for me I don't
even need this knife I think your side
cut right through holy hell
[Music]
you know what it is with tardo monks -
is that my art reaction you know it's so
good you know most people on food shows
they don't eat the food it's not me
the Jew so good chef thank you very much
for this amazing meal who know so won't
you let the people know where the
restaurants at your hours and how they
can get in on your dishes that's easy
okay we're located in the heart of
Waikiki 2330 Tokyo Avenue awesome thank
you very much chef thank you great
like [ __ ] Moses [ __ ] I've come
across the rest what